hello
I'm Glenn Beck and welcome to this very
special episode of the Reuben report
joining me today is a man who I think
has done the impossible and something
that I would love to do he has taken a
whole month away the entire month of
augment August no phone no news no media
no opinions were necessary nothing for
an entire month
welcome Dave Rubin to your own show it's
good to be here Glenn I gotta tell ya I
told my whole team this morning that I
never truly I never get nervous for any
of the stuff that I do I don't get
nervous for interviews I don't get
nervous for stand-up or touring or any
of that stuff
speaking of colleges I woke up this
morning and I was actually kind of
nervous not not about whatever you're
gonna yeah I know I think we literally
could be in World War 3 oh you know not
only knows what's happened I have no
idea what's happened truly I have
received no advance you like I haven't
spoken to your mother I haven't spoke to
my mom in weeks nobody I completely shut
down completely shut down
but the idea of just jumping right back
into the Internet just this machinery
horrible that people like us live on but
that we all live on to a degree is a
little like I'm actually having a little
bit anxiety I took two weeks I took two
weeks off had the same exact feeling to
where you're like I don't know if I
won't want to stick my toe back into
that cuz you know it's I mean wait yeah
well I'll say that well you know the
thing is that look I love what I do like
and I've realized one of the things that
I really realized this month or last
month it's just like how blessed I am to
just do what I you know I think is right
and what I want to do and it's growing
and I'm gonna make a couple
announcements at the end of this about
things that we're expanding on all that
and it's and it's fantastic but then
there's this other side of it that is
really making people crazy and we all
kind of know it and we talk about it
right and I talked about it with a lot
of guests about you know just the way
Twitter is and the fighting and all of
these things and the way politics is
divided
but then when you really step away from
it and I had a couple days on a beach
and I would watch people that were just
you know laying out at the beach oceans
crashing in front of them and they're
staring at their phones the entire time
what are you doing they legitimately
seem crazy like I started feeling like
the last sane man you know so it was it
was wild and I know you have plenty of
questions and your side me on things I
want to talk to you about taking that
time off and and I want to explore what
you just said how people look crazy
because I think we are going into some
sort of an insanity with all this but I
just want to give I want to give the
audience a sneak peek and you they will
know the answer to this if they've been
paying attention but you will have no
idea and as I was preparing last night I
thought I could read these headlines if
I had been unplugged I could read these
headlines and I would have absolutely no
idea which was true and which was false
okay all right two truths and a lie
oh okay so I give you two headlines that
are true one is a lie I'm gonna do yes I
want you to guess I'm not gonna tell you
we'll reveal it here a minute rusty
related to read I know right okay all
right headline number one yeah Trump
wants to buy Greenland headline number
two Trump suggests we nuke the hurricane
and headline number three
AOC triggered over a cardboard cutout
well that one sounds real to me that one
definitely sounds real to me before I
give you the answer I just have to say
one thing about Trump because when
you're off the grid you realize that not
everyone is talking about Trump no one
and almost no one is well the funny
thing is so for a couple of the days so
I really even though I wasn't online
doing things I was working in my own way
and as you know my my book got released
right before I left and I was doing
things related to that and editing and a
bunch of other stuff but for a couple of
days we went away and we were at this
resort and I'm you know doing the beach
thing and in the mornings they would
give all the people a sheet of paper
with the news in whatever language
people are inch one Italian an English
one and the only thing I saw all month
was I just saw two words
those and then I looked away and and I
just thought whatever it is boughs to
blow up Greenland or by Granada by
Greenland the hurricane he's like man
like it'll it'll happen whether I pay
attention or not so to answer your
question with a cardboard cutout
triggering a OC that sounds very legit
to me right which could be trunk trick
Trump saying he's gonna blow up a
hurricane sounds like the type of thing
that he would say right to trigger the
entire media and then I can blow up
hurricanes okay and then the other one
who is that he said he's gonna buy
Greenland yeah that's funny to me that
one sounds like the hurricane one sounds
so stupid but I think it's real you know
see one sounds within pretty much yeah
yeah so you're going so I'm going Trump
by and green from buying Greenland is
false his fault okay we'll come back to
that here second okay okay the second
the second one study finds humans are
biased against robots of color headline
number two trans activist Jessica Yaniv
do you remember yeah yeah trans activist
Jessica Deanna of tweets she can't go
into the pool today because her period
started and she forgot her tampons or
headline number three the internet and
why you gender studies department says
milking cows is like sexual assault and
raping cows which one is real there's
two real last one obvi these are all
real that's what it sounds like to me
but oh god the Jessica you need one
because that that story about this
waxing wax you know suing someone's like
that sounds right to me like that sounds
within the realm of the insanity that
that thing had been about so alright
okay alright was the first one the first
one was the Jessica en if I think no no
it was study finds humans are biased on
robots of color
yeah that sounds the
to me there's definitely gonna be a bit
about racism coming 13 so it's the NYU
study that says milking cows is akin to
rape god that sounds real - I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say Eve milking cows okay
alright alright so now we'll put that
around this just I'll add glad that you
started this yeah so yeah yeah yeah
because that's not those aren't really
the insane ones oh those are the big
stories that no those are not the big
stories a month they lasted you know a
day maybe those are have the big stories
oh so we'll get to that in a second yeah
first you went can I say where you went
let's not seem okay with yeah so you
went to Greenland yeah I'm surprised you
didn't hear but so you you went away for
two weeks you were here for two weeks
yeah you shut it all off I've tried to
get my family to do it and my wife will
say to me I can't I have too much to do
I get all of my communication through
here kids are doing blah blah blah
I hate say to her just ten years ago we
were able to do all this yeah
can't get people to true tune out well
that I think actually is the key to it
and I said that to a lot of people in
this last month because everywhere I
went people couldn't believe that I was
doing it so no matter where if I went to
the supermarket you're not gonna believe
this when I went to the supermarket I
had to write on a piece of paper the
things that I knew I had to buy because
I didn't have a phone with me a note
section so I would write I would take a
pen and a little notebook and I would
write out lettuce you know chin etc and
people would literally come up to me I
mean this happened every day no matter
where I went and said come on your phone
is on you I know your phones on you and
I would be emptying my pockets I go I
got nothing I got a I got a wallet
I did it my wallet but I what I really
realize is I need a phone for GPS I have
no sense of direction I could walk out
of my own house so that's one thing I
wanted to ask you well it's every the
one thing that you're like okay okay I
have to I can't wait until this comes
back so so GPS just in terms of like
functioning as a person now I do have
GPS built into my car so I was okay oh
you use so I guess that if that's using
the internet or whatever that is
yourself I did right so I did use that
but that really was it but but what your
wife said or what you said to your wife
about the 10 years ago this is how you
all behaved that really was like
rattling in my brain a lot because we
don't do a day without it now and maybe
some people do right ben shapiro does
sabbath also he's doing a 24-hour
operation and you know obviously people
have religious reasons to do it or every
night you know there are some detox
social media detox camps popping up and
things like that but what I realized was
and this is by the way the third August
that I've done this but you know as my
whatever you want to call it as my
profile has increased or whatever it's
gotten increasingly harder because I
have more responsibilities now and we
just made a couple new hires this week
that are going to talk about later and a
few other things but this the
neverending need to be connected is the
is the crazier part it's not it's not
the GPS part it's like this constant you
know you go to the supermarket and when
you're checking out 9 out of 10 times
you're most likely looking I can only
speak for myself I'm most likely looking
at my phone and I'm not paying attention
when the cashier says hi how are you and
I'll just mumble something back so this
is gonna sound crazy but just literally
the amount of eye contact that I've made
with people you know just in stores
saying hello to people like just being
jet you know being present I'm pretty
friendly guys you know I'm pretty I
think I'm pretty special II when I'm in
this room and I'm doing me I really can
do it cuz you've moved a lot of you know
it's funny that thousands of people
watch this but it feels like we're alone
right but like getting rid of that that
constant distraction never going oh I
tweeted something an hour ago is the is
the mob coming for me yeah or any of
those things even though I think
generally I have a pretty healthy
attitude toward it but not thinking
about any view counts or likes did you
find anything people liking things
constantly while you're sitting on a
beach and you're just waiting for the
likes to roll so so something really
care about halfway across the world
click the button one of the things that
has happened is Facebook is talking
about getting rid of likes okay so
that's that's real
it's real that's real they're talking
about getting rid of likes they're not
did I haven't decided yet but they're
talking about getting rid of likes well
one of the things I was thinking about a
lot about and this will get to something
that I'm going to announce in the second
half of all this is like the YouTube
situation for example where we both put
content on YouTube we're streaming on
YouTube right now you know we're just
outsourcing basically all of our
creativity to to these companies that we
have we really have no idea what's going
on and the more I stepped away from it
more crystal clear it came and you and I
think you and I are pretty much aligned
on that we don't want the government
coming in and breaking up these models
although I do think there's an
interesting argument now that the
founders could have never envisioned a
Power greater than government and
perhaps Google is greater than
government now so I think there's
philosophically some interesting things
to talk about there but what I realize
is is that you know YouTube really is
all it is is a search engine that's
that's throwing videos at you we have no
idea how they're manipulating all of
these things and I know I was talking
about all this stuff for the last year
or two before but when you really step
away from it and you start looking at
and you're out of the matrix yeah when
you're out of the matrix right you've
taken the red pill you're walking around
going wow look at all these zombies I
really was trying to think well how how
do we get clear information across and
how do we make sure that the world isn't
just absolutely divided by every
difference that we have so did you have
a did you have a well I think we'll get
to some of that I mean I think I there's
a couple business things that I'm about
to embark on that I think are gonna heal
some of that and it really more than
anything else as I said I felt very I
just feel very appreciative all month I
the people were nice every I didn't have
one bad experience truly I did not have
one I had two minor family health
related things that are okay now thank
God but I didn't have one negative
experience with the human I didn't have
you know I didn't go to Ikea and anyone
you know tell me to go [ __ ] myself or
whatever they're telling me on Twitter
right like every experience every person
that came up to me every person that I
talked to about this or that you know
the
friendlier with waiters I mean just like
little things like that I think we have
I think I fell kamar
I feel calmer now although I can feel
but I can feel the walls kind of coming
in oh it's gonna come in its land we're
back
yeah is you remember the scene in Star
Wars where they're in the trash
compactor Oh God the slug barracks it
was about to choke yeah yeah um you know
you you look at this and you know I took
I took my son across country we drove
across country for about a week and a
half we were driving and I had the same
thing I didn't have a bad experience
with anyone and it really I mean I got
here last night to Los Angeles you know
me in the Los Angeles Airport
ya know somebody says Glenn Beck you're
like best on me yeah yeah and the guy
said Glenn Beck and he said is anybody
told you you look exactly like Glenn
back yeah and I said I yeah I hear that
all the time that in Colonel Sanders
yeah and he said no you are the spinet
you're not going back are you no and I
said no and he said man you look just
like him I was just watching him this
morning and so I was like okay well
maybe it's a friendly it's where you
from he said Orange County and then I
knew okay he's safe he's okay I know I
know but I haven't even even in Los
Angeles people have been so great and so
gracious on this trip out into Los
Angeles that's not the way it seems to
be but we are all plugged in to this
machine and that's what I'm saying and
it's not who we are
well and then the algorithms that are
manipulating us to think different
things and we just again even though I
this is stuff that I've thought about
for a long time and we've talked about
on both of our shows when you really
step away from it you think well this is
just a search engine that's delivering
you these things or the way that we get
any of this information that we trust
that you know the Twitter feed and
manipulating us this way or shadow
banning us this way or that this video
is getting out to the right person this
way we have we have outsourced so much
of our ability to think clearly not
because we can't think about things or
we don't want to that's the other thing
that I really realized people really
really
want to start thinking clearly again I
mean that's why I wrote my book and I
think that's why it did pretty well 9/11
for its even on the shelves and that's
really like I I know like I am
dedicating the rest of my life to this
that kept popping up in to me like you
know like you know when you're just sort
of yeah you're on the right path and hey
you know I'm gonna make mistakes along
the way and all that but that that
people would come up so I'll tell you
this is gonna sound I'm just gonna it's
gonna sound disgustingly
self-aggrandizing but when I came back
from this trip that I went on I was
getting through customs here at LAX and
the border agent I handed in my passport
and he did a double-take and he took his
glasses off he was hit sunglasses on I
think he took his sunglasses off and he
looked me right in the eye and he said
name Ruben you're an American Hero I do
not think of myself as a hero in any way
anything even remotely close to that
mm-hmm but he said what you're doing for
free speech in blah blah blah and I just
thought I shouldn't be I I don't think
I'm a hero and I shouldn't be a hero you
know to me I think this has changed Dave
when I first got into radio I had to go
take a test at the FCC I had to go then
find a job with a corporation then I had
to hope to be discovered it's kind of
like with comedy you know that
somebody's gonna walk in and discover
and you have to go through all these
gates now you don't have to yeah so
there are I really think there's no one
hero anymore there's a collection yeah
it's happening all over the world I was
just in Australia meeting people in
Australia the same way it's everyone's
doing their part and soon I think we're
gonna see how they all kind of snap
together and that wave changes the
course well that was the other cool part
of what happened to me in this past year
you know I went on tour with Jordan
Peterson yeah for a hundred I think I
did a hundred and ten of the hundred
thirty show something like that we go
you know two dozen countries and when we
were in Australia or whether we were in
you know Sweden or Canada the idea that
we're talking to these audiences and
remove me altogether forget what I was
doing Jordan he goes up there a
different hour and a half lecture about
existentialism or religion or
in reality or politics or media or
whatever else but a different lecture
every night stretching the limits of
what he can think about and what he can
do and trying to be true and through
doing that the amount of people that he
changed you were you were at the show in
Dallas yes I was I mean I'm I hope I'm
not embarrassing you but you you cried
after you came you came into the
dressing room after and you had tears in
your eyes yeah because it was it was I
can't remember exactly what I said but I
I realized that the people in the
audience were so hungry for someone to
say it's okay to think differently it's
okay you're smart enough to figure this
out and it's okay to be different and I
saw it wash over this audience and I
remembered my time at Yale where I had a
professor say the same thing he's I had
so such low self-esteem of my intellect
and he said we were he asked me up to
lunch because we had an argument in
class about something and I said no you
told me not to read that guy you told me
to read this book and I did now answer
my question about this guy and he said
see me after class so what are you doing
here and I told him I'm just trying to
figure out life and at one point he
reached over and he grabbed my hand and
he said you know you're smart enough to
be here right and I didn't yeah that's
what I felt with Jordan Peterson we're
being told all the time were racist
Rosina phobes we're horrible people were
white or black and that means something
that's not who we are and we're getting
constantly told this it's time for
somebody just to say you're smart enough
you're decent enough you're good enough
here's some thoughts that you probably
use some of you might understand some of
you might get 60% of but that 60% is
you're thinking that's what I want to be
part of yeah that's me that's what I
want to do it's what I've been trying to
do and it's absolutely what I'm gonna
double down on going forward you know
I'm not I could look at a lot of the
books that I have on this set of great
thinkers
you know there's Neil Ferguson and Peter
Thiel and Steven Pinker and all these
great people and Bob Saget
right that's great man's right he is a
great man but you know I want to keep
helping people like that and it doesn't
have to be people that are just Harvard
professors or big TV chairs or whatever
I there are so many more people out
there that want to get these ideas
across and somehow through over the last
five or whatever years by me just
talking about what my own evolution was
I created something that we're sitting
in my garage right out and it and it's
pretty cool pretty nice not bad for a
garage yeah but you know again just to
jump back to that that 10-year thing
about how much everything's changed
it's just also about the rate of speed
that it's changing at we have no idea
Jordan actually talked about this a
little bit in some of the shows we have
no idea this thing that I haven't had on
me for the last 33 days how fast being
slammed with so much information and
real news and fake news and manipulated
box and the rest of it how much it is
changing us so quickly but I don't think
we've even come close to realizing know
what it's gonna do to us
and that's the thing I mean 20 you know
I'm not that old
I turned in June I turned 43 43 or 44
how old am I
43 and jeez I really I turned 43 and you
know I told the story cold times but I
remember the first time I saw the
Internet in pictures I had first I
remember a vague thing at the beginning
of college when it was this around 94
and it was just text I had an email
address there was just a bunch of
numbers I didn't know what I was gonna
do with it but I remember sophomore year
at college kid down the hallway starts
screaming he's on the internet he's on
the internet and I go a bunch of us go
into his room and there's the computer
and it has a Yankees logo and a Royals
lobik says Yankees three Royals won and
I swear to god I remember saying
tininess thing I've ever seen because it
was like why wouldn't I watch
SportsCenter to figure that out in two
hours that was roughly 20 years ago you
know barely so it's like this thing is
happening so fast and but it's not just
that that's happening fast we don't know
how to behave with it you know and it's
like that's the other you know about the
destruction part of all I was I was
having I was having lunch with
in regards to something else that I'll
talk to you about that's happened here
just in the last few days I was with
jason blum you know who he asked from
Blum house hey we were having lunch and
we don't agree on a lot we love each
other I mean the first time I think I
had 20 minutes
he said his secretary said in his office
this like 10 years ago we ended as she
came in she's like it's 5:30 he's got to
go and he's like no no we're good 6
o'clock he's got to go now we're good we
ended up having dinner at a steak house
until like 2 o'clock in the morning love
the guy
just a different thinker an innovative
guy yeah
breaks all the rules we're sitting and
and talking about how crazy it is that
we we can't talk to each other and we're
allowing these fringes if you look at
the world is like a football field
we got 15% on the uber left and 15% on
the uber right and the rest of everybody
on the fields like really we have to
follow these guys I don't agree with
either of those guys it's not that
you're a mushy middle you'll have real
passions but you're not the crazies and
we're we're listening to those crazies
because they now have a microphone those
people always exist they were they were
Bob down at the corner of our street
well that we told our kids hey I don't
know Bob's a little weird don't talk to
Bob okay but we you know we'd pass him
and go hey Bob and we've never talked
about right now Bob that Bob's gone now
Bob Scott as I need to right and he's
found all the other Bob's in our
neighborhood yeah
let him talk we don't we don't need to
pay attention to them we don't have to
pay any attention or give them any
regard we used to pass them they still
had those views we just passed them yeah
the problem with that though is that the
institutions that we should trust have
become so corrupt that when you hear
Bob's screaming something crazy often
it's as truthful as what the
institutions are telling you right so
like the New York Times for example that
and I see this now because they've gone
after me a couple of times and you know
the article about the radicalization to
the alright and my picture my head right
there and my dad who
who's a New York liberal for the last
you know a subscriber of the New York
Times wrote 45 years has to open up the
Sunday Times while he's getting a bagel
in Long Island and one of his friends
come up to him said David all right I
mean that literally happened right so
when the institutions are crumbling to
the point that they're peddling nonsense
like that well the more they do that
then Bob starts looking kind of sane and
I think that that will be it will
definitely be my challenge and I think
it'll be the challenge for you and for
for any of us that care about what we're
talking about here to resolve this no I
think it's no I think it's up to the
American people to reset it and to say
okay well we got accommodate a path
maybe yeah I know but we we all we have
to do is speak the truth and then ask
them to go do their own homework and
reject things that sound too good or
make you feel so good that's probably
not entirely true
you know not everyone who disagrees with
you politically is automatically that's
a weird thing is that seems so I know
you're telling me that I know possibly
not true you know Brigitte fantasy yeah
she was in my studio a couple weeks ago
I just did her something else that's
developed yeah just did her podcast my
podcast on Bridget's podcast me being
interviewed by her was banned from
Facebook this weekend because it
violated the community standards you
going on her podcast me which she then
posted on her face Brian
correct have you have you heard
Bridget's podcast yeah I mean I know
community standards from the FCC side
that's I mean I listened to her that
that's violating those community
standards I said nothing
nothing controversial in it I'm banned
that's craziness craziness they they're
coming for us
and that sounds paranoid it sounds kind
of paranoid it sounds kinda paranoid I
know trust me I didn't like that thought
ever you know one of the things I
noticed was when you take some time off
and you and you can just kind of think a
little bit I'm not not just be slammed
by information although I did feel a
little bit like my brain was just kind
of purging nonsense there were a couple
times during the month but like an old
song would pop in my head that
and thought of didn't forever and
they're like why did that just pop in my
head it's because my brain was actually
able to get rid of some of my garbage
but but related to what you just said
about about Bridget and podcast in the
bay it's like well why are we giving
them so much power
what well I've got an answer to some of
that right here ok gotta talk about a
little bit sorry so can we get into the
let's get was a little bit let's get
into the news so we could be at World
War 3 you might tell me that right now
in which case so if i if we're in World
War 3 I don't think I'd be here but
having a casual chat actually the garage
is quite secure
it does seem it ok first let's start
with oh wait can I just say one other
thing so the last thing that I remember
just to give people a little context
about you know timing in every job the
last story that I saw before I shut down
the whole thing was that Mario Lopez of
Saved by the Bell
and I believe extra is the TV show he's
on was banned or something he did
something truly hateful he said to
Candace Owens of all people he said to
Candace Owens on her show that four year
olds that say they're transparent
probably think about that a little bit
before necessarily endorsing it or yeah
and and it was his apology that was the
last thing I heard nothing
not that obviously didn't we all don't
to be true but his apology was the last
thing that I heard they didn't accept it
and they executed him no people get up
every day like who shall we destroy
today yeah that was his day they
destroyed him on that day and then we
moved on and we haven't thought about
him since ok yeah so here are the
headlines
Trump buys Greenland what did you say
true or false I think that was the one
that I said he wants to buy Green yeah
yeah it's true in fact all of the Trump
why did do that you said all of those
were true they were all true
he said bombing the hurricane just was
like that's so obvious because that's
yeah you know why can't we love a nuke
in there because it doesn't work that
way ok he moved on but the press just
loved it really he wants to buy green
and you know what it actually he's not
the only president has tried it Truman
what I think was the last one might been
an Eisenhower but I think it was Truman
he was the last one it's all kinds of
rich with all kinds of minerals etc etc
but what he really wants we already have
air bases up there it goes way into the
Russian airspace and we were looking at
that apparently as the base sounds a
little crazy for the space force where
do you buy Greenland is it on Denmark
now here's what happened so dead right
it's not for sale but it is it's run by
Denmark okay if you've heard this but
Denmark you know it's not a big country
we've got lots of money because we can
print it in our basements yeah so he's
he just blurted out in a speech you know
what I think we should look at buying
Denmark now I mean duh buying a
Greenland and people are like that's
very easy series he was serious he then
said I'm on my way over to see the Queen
or whoever you know Princess Ella and
you know what's-her-name from frozen
yeah Elsa she's running green or Denmark
he said I'm going over I want to meet
with her not about Greenland but some
other things too and she immediately
tweeted it's not for sale
we're not interested in this and he said
he comes out and he said that's great at
least she's honest and her business
dealings she didn't string us along she
just said no we're moving on do you
realize that the news has become an
episode of veep did you watch beep on HP
Drive it's like that sounds like an
episode of veep the whole thing sounds
like an episode of some comedy or horror
show the the entire world is so wait I
just just understand this a little
better so when Trump said it though it
was just one of the sort of slapstick
off-the-cuff nonsensical yeah he said it
and then I think he said it in a meeting
he said like the like the nukes the
Hurricanes thing he said it in a meeting
and you know everybody's leaking and so
he said in the meeting and somebody said
news guy wants to buy Greenland and
he just got on Twitter it was like yeah
I do it's a good it's a good deal to
think of it as a great real estate
investment it actually I know a lot of
people make fun of it I actually kind of
liked it it kind of made me feel good it
kind of made me feel like yeah okay much
better than invading countries right yes
seems better
we're also negotiating with the Taliban
looks like we are at the end in 15
months all troops will be out of
Afghanistan well that would be
absolutely amazing I'm actually it'll be
great I'm thrilled to hear that yeah I
mean I'm sure you know this but it's the
longest war in American history yeah I
know it's crazy what's going on Donald
Trump's been saying it forever the media
should be celebrating curse what how are
they painting it we're cutting and
running we're leaving them yeah we have
no negotiation power why are we why is
Trump doing this he's given away all of
our power all of this - I mean it's nuts
see a story like that is where you
really see the absurdity of the media
right like getting out of Afghanistan
which should every lefty in their right
mind should be for everyone period she
we don't know why we're there the 9/11
hijackers weren't from there I
understand why you'd want to get rid of
the Taliban because of oppression of
their own people and all that kind of
stuff but you know also 9/11 was you
know 18 plus years ago but that type of
story we're leaving war right that's the
left likes to get out of wars right
there the peace people know what they
say you've got to be all about that but
Trump has created this situation where
the media and otherwise somewhat
clear-thinking people can take any
position on anything as long as it's
counter to him it's I mean it's just
sort of a fascinating psychological
health in that for a while no no I
thought it was I thought it was in July
but it may have been in August Iran took
over a couple of ships they fired shot
he and then he called off a suit role
that was one of the last things okay
right so where's the press on that one
they're still calling him a warmonger
the guy said no I don't I don't want it
I don't think this is reciprocal I don't
think this is bad
at all no don't want to do it that's a
good thing you know it's funny one of
the last interviews I did before I left
I had Marianne Williamson on and I'm
sure we're doing she's still still in
she's still are they all still in no I
will but real quick on that I asked when
I had Williamson on I asked her about
Trump calling off that strike I said
does he deserve ad credit and she
basically said no and I thought and I
treat her with the same respect I treat
everybody else all my interviews that's
her opinion that's fine but I thought
this is the inherent problem if if
another your president had called off
the strike you'd be saying he deserves a
Nobel Prize but the guy you hate calls
off a strike because he didn't want
something like 200 civilians to be
killed yeah I called a good thing now
you take the position though he doesn't
deserve any credit for it and it's that
sort of constant dishonesty that
constant dishonesty that's keeping us
going around in this it's like a planet
that's like looping around something
that just keeps getting faster in fact I
know you feel the same way I was talking
to somebody the other day and I said how
is it that if you say one thing there's
lots of stuff about Donald Trump that I
like okay lots of stuff I really don't
like I take it piece by piece it's like
a Trump smorgasbord I'll take a little
of that none of that and some of this
he's our president so I'll judge him on
what he's doing you say one thing
against him and you're for the
slaughterhouse on one side you say one
thing for him and you are the biggest
Trump supporter yeah why can't we start
looking at things and saying you know
what this was a good move I don't agree
with him on a lot of things that's a
good move you can watch videos when the
Trump thing just started right when you
just start and I think you were
adamantly against Trump at the time
right at the beginning right yeah so you
can watch me toes just when it started
when I still considered myself a big
lefty and all that where I was saying in
my direct message as I kept saying you
know if you keep calling this guy a Nazi
who's probably just kind of a New York
corrupt businessman yes you know trying
to you know get some power here or
whatever it is if you keep calling him a
Nazi it's not what you're doing to him
that's going to be the problem it's what
you're doing to yourself because if you
keep saying this guy's Hitler well now
you've really painted yourself into a
corner because now Hitler does some good
things right the economy is kind of
chugging along we might get out of
Afghanistan we're not bombing Iran you
know these tax cuts we deregulated some
stuff some things that most of Americans
think are pretty good
well you can't suddenly be like you know
that Hitler guy yeah you know Hitler did
make the Autobahn no one credits Hitler
for the auto correct it was his but I'm
not gonna give him credit for it but but
that sort of that absurd over-the-top
way of categorizing people especially
Trump but I don't know hopefully remotes
but do it try my Trump here but that
thing where they do that with everything
and creates it's not that it's not what
you're doing to that person it's what
you're doing to yourself you're putting
yourself in a prison by doing that
you're putting yourself in an idealised
well they enough to how do you now CNN
was totally fine defended a guest that
said Donald Trump you know this I
believe was a psychiatrist from maybe
John Hopkins
well CNN sure that was that guy yeah
said that he's crazy he's crazy and he
he has the potential of killing more
people than Hitler Stalin and Mao
combined
okay so CNN quits this person on ya know
push back see this is welcome back to
CNN yeah this is not news and that's
what people really need to understand
this is not news I'm not perfect what I
do in this room and I'm sure I drop you
all I do what you and I do our opinions
yeah we we are paid to filter through
all the crap and say this you should pay
attention to this you shouldn't and
encourage our audience to do their own
homework and if I got it wrong let me
know you know or dismiss me as a coop
because you've done your homework but
isn't it interesting that news is not
supposed to be that way not well not
right so a that's not news right now CNN
can put it right ever they want right
but it's it's guys din that this is some
sort of authoritarian authoritative new
source when it's not what it is is it's
keeping people hysterical so I hear that
that's like you immediately said to me
it sounds hilarious it's hilarious
because it should be an ad aqua c2 yes
but it shouldn't be in reality so it's
like for two years let me get this
straight for two years Rachel Maddow
could keep pushing the Russia hoax thing
right and it's like does she get banned
or I don't want her to be bad but like
did advertisers well I don't know maybe
no no she hasn't
no yeah but the point is that you can
peddle all sorts of nonsense and you can
say Trump has the psychological makeup
to to murder hundreds of millions of
people there's no paint there's no
payback there's no there's no risk on
one side but on the other side there's a
hella but now you're gonna tell me ya
know I was just gonna tell you I can't
find it in here I may not have made the
cut but the New York Times this month it
was revealed through I think
correspondence and and memo form I'm not
sure but it was their plan and they said
phase one was Trump and Russia just run
with Trump and Russia we're about to
enter phase two and now phase two
they've got a new plan I can't remember
what it is but they have a new plan
meaning this is like a direct this is a
directive to all of the reporters this
is how we're gonna get him yeah that's
not news news that's not even a good
opinion site and and you know I always
say this but it's like that's why what I
said earlier about the the institutions
I don't want the New York Times to
crumble I would prefer it didn't I would
prefer it did its job so that we could
make a distinction between the pretty
decent things you know because if we
have no let's say we have no level of
gatekeeping whatsoever and no
authoritative somewhat trustworthy
sources then we're really screwed cuz
then Bob who you were talking about but
everyone's Bob and then it's like well
how are we gonna ever trust anything in
this world how are we gonna ever trust
an election result or absolutely
anything I've talked about this for
years on my show this the the special
forces told me in 2006 I say what's the
that's the thing that keeps you guys up
at night this is Special Forces
headquarters
they said the Bubba effect and I say
what the hell's a Bubba effect and they
said when Bubba decides you know the
government is lied to us
the media has lied to us this 2006
everybody's lied to us and yeah Bubba
sees a guy coming in and he's a Sikh and
he's got a turban and there's just been
another bad bombing or something and he
takes it out and shoots the guy with a
turban everyone in town knows Bubba is
wrong but when the feds come in everyone
in town says he's ours to deal with you
people have been lying and you people
have stirred bub up to this yeah you
know what I mean
that's that's that was their biggest
concern coming in 2006 I think we're
there I think that's Trump is not the
disease Trump is a symptom absolutely
exit is not the disease it's a symptom
and it's happening all around the world
you know it's interesting so Bragg's it
I got to tell you something funny so two
days ago three days ago the only thing
that I did that was sort of semi grid
was that I went to Candice Owens wedding
now I know people don't like that I'm
friends with Kenya but I am friends
mechanis and she's a great girl and I
went to her wedding in Virginia and at
her wedding
Nigel Faraj and larry elder and dennis
prager and a whole bunch of political
people and it's two days before i'm
trying to stay off the grid and there
was this rumor that Trump was gonna be
there and I had to go up to every person
at that wedding
Nigel Nigel Freddie I swear man oh I
died to talk to Nile
came up to me today we've met yeah yeah
yeah he came up to me to start talking
about brexit and I said sorry I can't
talk I mean that's what I know what's
happened in Great Britain at all did he
know no he saw it saying something about
Britain today had an election we they
had another in the last month that they
had an election of a new Prime Minister
I know Boris Johnson kay so you know
that was okay that was a right thing
okay yeah right at the end yeah all
right so now he has I think it's called
prorogue he has asked the Queen to
disband Parliament and Parliament is has
been disbanded by the Queen for five
weeks
and England the left the Labour Party is
all upset they're saying this is
unprecedented it really happens every
year they take about two weeks where the
Prime Minister says its Perot and we're
gonna disband so you guys can take care
of the local things we're not gonna talk
about national things you could take
care of the things you have to in your
own district cleaner yeah and just you
can be here but we're not meeting on
anything so they do that every year for
they do that every year for one to two
weeks but most I think has ever been
done is four weeks and maybe maybe that
was in World War two he's just done it
for five weeks and the Labour Party
doesn't like it because they're saying
let me guess let me guess he's a fascist
yes yes it was a coup yeah so they're
claiming that it's a coup he says no we
can't get any deal from Europe if we
have Congress power I mean Parliament
constantly telling them they need to
understand I'm serious I'm gonna pull us
out of the EU it's the only way they're
gonna offer any kind of deal better than
what we have is if they know I've got a
little bit of a twitchy eye and I just
might do it I think he's right yeah well
look the brexit thing so I so I'm
guessing this is now being framed as
okay so he's a fascist the racists are
all about it well it was for about the
brexit people are the people that
supported Briggs that are probably
supporting yes this so it's about it was
like that for about a week and then we
moved on to destroy something else yeah
so for a week there it was bad but they
are they in the midst of this they're in
week two it just happened like I think
last week you know it's it's it's still
new but it's over you know what can
happen
five weeks are gonna go by hopefully
some of those members of parliament will
have gone back to their districts and
done some of the things that you'd like
them to do like where I live in out in
LA off my exit over here by the Oro 5 I
would love them to clean up there's a
lot of homeless trash is horrible yeah
it's pretty bad here in LA right then
here it was a year ago that I was here
it's already changed this is horrible it
has gotten significantly worse here I
would love to
and David has actually contacted our
local congressman because there's a
trash compactor bait it's basically a
dump by our by our exit over here but I
bet you what's gonna happen is in five
weeks some of those guys are to go back
to their districts they're gonna clean
up some stuff and fascism is not going
to arise because some politicians went
back to their districts to talk to the
people there voted I mean it's a fascism
or fascism I think arise especially it's
mostly local yeah right fascism I think
arises when people feel like they can't
trust anybody and that the government
isn't listening and so then the
government has to use a strong arm to do
things and that's what's happening now
the Labour Party is saying well that was
an old election that voted for brexit
that's not what the people want today
maybe we should have another election
that is what when we had an election and
we voted the Tea Party members in and
they almost all of them betrayed the
American people when we elected
Democrats or Republicans and put them in
the House and the Senate and the White
House and then they still didn't do
anything about Obamacare done that's why
you what that's why a lot of people say
I like Donald Trump he's burning it all
down you know it's interesting though
it's it is both sides on that because
you could even think to Obama's first
two yes he had
correct he had the Senate he had the
Congress and he could have passed
Obamacare that way and he didn't anyway
did correctly after that so they they
all they all do it but I think the
brig's a thing which I was thinking a
lot about the last couple days because
because Faraj was there it's like if
they don't do it now I know I would have
been for it if I lived there from
everything I understand about brexit
because I like you I'm a small
government guy and I would want the
power to be back within my sovereign
nation right yeah and then my local
community yeah but if they don't do it
after the votes and the revote sand
everything I had what does that say to
the future of Western democracy what
does that say when when France has a
vote that doesn't go the way that the
powers that be correct it happened what
it happens here correct it it's the same
story all around the world now by the
way Hong Kong Hong Kong exporting
plastic toys I know not China Hong Kong
yeah the people in the millions are
in the streets they have been protesting
peacefully they took over the airport
for a while they had to shut it down
Chinese military gathering on the border
they have already sent troops in
yesterday they said that those who are
protesting the end has come
so they're basically protesting China
rule over they there was this really
weird story this guy went over to Taiwan
and he killed his girlfriend they went
on this trip
she said eh by the way I'm pregnant and
it's not your child he freaked out he
killed her okay
then he put her in the suitcase then he
drove around Taiwan found a place dumped
her body took her credit card took some
money got on a plane went back to Hong
Kong well by the time he landed in Hong
Kong Taiwanese police found it and went
wait a minute dead body where's the
boyfriend tracked him back to Hong Kong
well Hong Kong does not have any
extradition with with Taiwan so the guy
was getting away with it
so China said we will extradite him
we'll try him in China well then the
Hong Kong people said whoa whoa whoa
wait we don't want any extradition stuff
because you'll just start scooping
people up off the street that's pretty
fascinating no matter how evil what you
happen it went down weird our sovereign
yeah and nobody really pays attention to
what really started it yeah but when you
see it was a murder an ugly grisly
murder that started it and now it is
turned into just basic human rights of
we want to be free and China they've
they've in the protests they take these
green lasers and they're doing this to
confuse all of the security cameras
because and they're all wearing masks
they look like antiphon yeah but they're
not and they're wearing masks because
all of the cameras are printing who they
are so how is the media framing this
thing you know they made another statue
of the Statue of Liberty like they did
in Tiananmen Square they in in one of
the most remarkable scenes I have seen
in a long time they stood together and
they were waving the American flag Wow
and they sang our star-spangled banner
they were begging us to notice them
so Trump I'm sure now is giving the
people of Hong Kong some support right
some at least verbally really mm-hmm
staying out of it he said I hope things
and peacefully
we're always for freedom for all sides
but when you look at it unless you want
to get involved and I don't yeah what do
we do were at this place I wish he was
more vocal about it because that's the
way Reagan and Pope John Paul and
Margaret Thatcher collapsed the Soviet
Union is they spoke that way but at the
same time China has retaliated on our
tariffs Trump took our tariffs up a
Apple and everybody took it up another I
think it's 25 percent now horrible we
are now approaching smoot-hawley record
levels of tariffs China said oh really
we'll do this and they put I don't
remember what it was eighty billion or
some ungodly number we've kind of backed
away from each other here for a minute
but if this isn't solved this is not
good for either of us China just printed
50 trillion dollars of currency 50 the
whole if you stack all the money in the
world up all the cash in the world that
is 60 trillion they just printed 50
trillion and dumped it into half of it
into their economy and half of it into
our wall street so is this thing still
burning this hot right now this happened
in the last couple days yeah it's been
happened in the last two weeks maybe
last week and a half to what what will
be interesting I mean this is I can only
comment that from a sort of you know sky
level would be it'll be interesting to
see how the media either keeps things
going or just drops it all together
because one of the things that I think
all the time is that one of the the
media's biggest failures it's not just
the misreporting and lying and
misquoting and all that it's what they
choose not to cover so
then something happens somewhere in Hong
Kong or in China or in Taiwan or
anywhere else Greenland or Denmark we
know nothing about what their political
system is we know nothing about their
cultural system the religious norms any
of those things but then ever I'm sure
everyone on Twitter is now an expert in
Taiwanese politics right over in Hong
Kong no it's pretty much being with Hong
Kong paid attention to I think it wasn't
a lead story you know with the people I
think people are so sick of of the wars
yeah they were like what are we gonna do
we're gonna do we're gonna take on China
too so I don't think people felt like
there was anything they could do I think
their thoughts and prayers are with the
people of Hong Kong fighting for the
Liberty crew don't you think because for
a guy like you that doesn't want to be
an interventionist but you care about
Liberty you care about into individual
freedoms and all that that you said you
well you'd want Trump maybe to be a
little bit more like Reagan or Thatcher
no just in his speech just empowering by
speech you can't do it just by speech
because there has to be something behind
it there has to be the idea that
something could be behind it right so we
put so it's an odd I find that to be one
of the interesting most interesting sort
of or rich places for libertarians or
Liberty minded people to debate about
things because it's like we care I think
we care the most about other people
being free I want everyone to be free I
don't care what color they are or what
nationality they are anything I thought
it's not enough justice but it's not
enough just to say and then on the other
hand do you then want to use force No so
because it becomes it no it doesn't it
what we've lost is our ability to
believe in ourself a few years ago they
Isis was taking all these use it ease
and all these Christians as slaves well
just this year we've saved I think
another fifty thousand we've just I just
was in an Australia reuniting a mother
with her two daughters that had they
thought they were they were both all
three of them taken his slaves they all
thought they each other were dead put
him together we're not people that have
any experience in this it just takes
people to say you know what like Thomas
Paine did he went to France to help them
he happened to be wrong on that he
corrected that immediately he knew oh
wait this is
like the Revolution in America but it's
up to individuals to go and yes we can
do something to help you I don't know
what it is
yeah as I haven't thought about this
that's not my thing mine is this over
here but we all have to be involved and
now with the internet we're all
empowered that's what scares the
government mmm is that you have the
power and you didn't have to go through
anyone yeah one of the things I write
about in the book is the bravery deficit
which is actually a phrase that I think
Bridgette said as he said to me that I
credit are always with me but that we
are in such a situation of a bravery
death
that's the only reason anyone knows
about what I do and probably half the
reason they know about what you do and
you know I mean all these people that
now are catching on purchase guitars
Jordan what is it it's not just yes it's
he a brilliant psychologist does he have
an incredible understanding of the Bible
and of history and all of those things
sure nobody's debating into that but
that's not why they're coming they're
coming because of the bravery so things
are changing so there's been a comedy
special released by Dave Chappelle okay
it was released i oh god let me guess he
hates black people now oh yeah he hates
everything he hates everybody his his
special is quite possibly the most
genius loving George Carlin style joke
yeah deep thinking wait a minute you're
laughing out loud and then you're like
wait a minute I think he just flipped
that all around I mean like really
enough okay zero
critics ratings on Rotten Tomatoes zero
and they haven't released what the
people are saying this is brilliant
he's now they're trying to you know
smear him right they're gonna say yeah
they're gonna give him the Kayne
treatment this guy is brave smart and
here's what makes him so dangerous
really funny yeah that's great to hear
is it on Netflix or yeah it's on Netflix
oh I can't wait to see it and that's
that is what will break their backs it
will do it right it's comedy
come back comedy is making a comeback
yeah listen Oh Joe Rogan have you seen
the Joe Rogan special yet that probably
came out in August oh my gosh is that
funny and it's right on the same point
yeah I mean at one point and both of
them kind of did stuff like this but but
Chappelle said you know who you know
who's real pain in the ass these people
who if I've ever done anything wrong in
15 years all of a sudden they're
emailing they're complaining they're
Boyka he describes and all the people
are giving him clapped her yeah take it
on and he says you know who I'm talking
about
you talking about you yeah he is just
taking a hard stand on you're all doing
it all of you yeah well we're all doing
we are we're we are guilty of it we are
right yeah I actually I read addicted
outraged finally over your last book
over 20 there's a very nice shout out to
me which thank you thank you but I
finally got to read it cuz I was able to
actually read books yeah in this last
month we don't do that i read dennis
prager book over here and all and I'd
read 12 rules but I was able to read a
few of these but we're all doing it and
we and that's what I mean about the
speed of all of this and you know it's
so funny because all of the people that
that are constantly trying to destroy
everybody online they are the same
people who post their whole life online
and if you play by that rule do you not
think that some societal norm in twenty
thirty two is gonna make you look evil
do you not think that if you try to
destroy everybody from the past and
every political person who spoke to
somebody else at some point but they're
not gonna come and take down the Obama
library because Obama ran against gay
marriage the first time which he did
what do you think the progressives of
2032 yeah they're done with they're done
with a while that's crazy nice by the
way
you bought a 14 million dollar house
Palm Springs no no no if you believe the
world is gonna end in 12 years because
of global warming No oh because of
global warming global warming is gonna
be warm wanna go rivers er you know the
sea levels are gonna rise he's gone like
that mountain in Tibet where'd he go
right no he bought beachfront property
in Martha's Vineyard
14 sorry yeah okay 14 million dollars
that's a 12 year investment that's no
that's definitely a 12 year investment
yeah that's that's a lot of money for
you probably got one of those ten-year a
RM yeah no you're good that's a balloon
in the last two yeah but all of that
nine so it's like that type of thing
like the aoc 12 years yeah ever and that
we had conversations then or the
national dialogue and the way that
people react to each other on cable news
the rest of it as if these are serious
spots by serious people who have any as
if like AOC is a great again but I
didn't think about her once for the
month actually until you said her name
there truly she did not and it was
refreshing is yeah oh yeah he's kind of
faded they've had died yeah there was
there was a scandal with Talib and OMA
and Omar there's a couple of scandals
you're gonna love yeah you know she
married her brother so so that is true
like we have we have so on it so we have
all the documentation on it nobody let's
put it this way the state of Minnesota
said we can't prove that these are
untrue and she's not cooperating it
absolutely looks it falls the ice she's
also been paying her boyfriend for
consulting and she's paying him like
literally fourteen thousand on Monday
twelve thousand on Tuesday twenty-six
thousand on Wednesday they're writing
checks out and nobody knows why this
guy's a hell of a consultant this guy
this guy must be good at something yeah
must be good at something but she was
gonna go with Talib Rashid Talib yeah
and they were gonna go to Israel right
and I remember that there was I remember
that discussion was being had right
before I went to write I go no okay
because Trump called Benjamin Netanyahu
and said you know they're going for the
BDS thing which you can't go to Israel
if you're part of BDS yeah so is Israel
which are already has that rule yeah
said you're not welcome here okay they
pitched a fit just pitched a fit well
they were being sponsored by
a group whose own website talks about
Israel I wish I had it if somebody can
bring in my iPad I have to read it job
I'm guessing evil Zionists it's got oh
yeah it's crazy it is like it's like
Hitler stuff it's crazy what they had on
their own website so close this is the
least crazy thing you told me this yeah
I know it just seems obvious yeah I know
that's what they are
so they said so they get on TV and
Rasheed to leave is like my sick
grandmother is there and now I can't go
see my sick grandmother so Benjamin
Netanyahu said you know what we're gonna
give you an exception you can come in to
visit your sick grandmother well I'm not
gonna go see my grandmother under these
conditions unbeliev unbelievable
unbelievable is it great
it's this this this is the greatest
comedy show ever written yeah it's just
all true like where are the good that's
the thing they're here they're they know
I know they're here because they they
watch this and they say hi to me and you
know all that I know they exist because
I was one of them and they're in my
family yeah but when I say send it over
thank you but when it's like where are
the good liberals that go sorry to leave
and sorry Omar and aoc they're coming so
because if they can resurrect the
Democratic Party and the same and a sane
liberalism you know as I've said I'll
have a Mia culpa and I will gladly be
like wow I was wrong on that whole thing
you guys did it
you guys really did it so I I had a I
had a dinner I was supposed to go to
last night with somebody and somebody
went and my plane was late so he just
way this guy's disguise a really big
liberal I mean really really big liberal
and he said what the hell is wrong with
the Democratic Party what are they doing
he's like I'm going to vote for Donald
Trump because they've lost their mind
this guy would never vote for a
Republican yeah let alone Donald Trump
and he told the ITO
this friend of mine there are a lot of
people out in LA and Hollywood who
aren't saying anything but they're
they're scared of these people that are
saying we're gonna end the free market I
completely agree and I see that all the
time and I see it in LA look it's not
the LA thing is it particularly weird
why did Peter teal move from San
Francisco if he wanted to go to a
conservative Haven probably could have
gone closer to where you're live in
these days but he didn't right he came
to LA you know Shapiro's in LA I'm in LA
there's not it's not that we're all
conservative per se but something else
something's happening here because
you're willing to have a conversation
with anyone who's just not trying to win
all the time they just look I want to
figure things out I got I have a story
on on that that yeah will you let me
just read this yeah this was this was
actually published by these this group
that sponsored them they were like no
we're just going to see our relatives
and our sick grandma the Jew controlled
entertainment media has taken the lead
in Perseids persuading a whole
generation that homosexuality is normal
and an acceptable way of life that there
is nothing at all wrong with the white
women dating or marrying black men or
white men marrying an Asian woman that
all races are inherently equal in
ability and character except that the
character of the white race is suspect
because of a history of oppressing other
races and that that any effort by whites
at racial self-preservation is
reprehensible
they were sponsored by what sounds like
a white supremacist yes no it's a group
it's no they published this yes read
they're controlling you know they turn
to people gay okay well let that go
they're the white black people can sorry
right this was a subgroup that they saw
and went you know what that article is
worth publishing on our site they
published that article from a white
supremacy group but this but they are
but they are supremacists in their own
way but they shouldn't surprise anybody
because no I won't why do these women
still show up with farik
you know you mean because they know if
you're on the left there is no left that
is too far left to be associated with
you can always wiggle your way out of it
but if the Democratic governor of
Virginia let's say shows up in blackface
he's gonna get out of it - because he's
a Democrat so you can raise get out but
if anyone on the right does anything
mean this is the way this is for me to
say all of this now - for me to be in
the position that I am now raising he's
such an up ending of everything that
that I always thought was right I know
and and again I think no it says nothing
I don't think use well I think you still
believe the things I used to believe you
just realized that the people you were
with were not honest brokers of that
that's a better way to describe it it's
not an up ending of everything I used to
believe because I because although I've
shift I've totally admitted I've shifted
on some economic or serve or libertarian
or whatever so it's not an up ending of
everything I believe it's an up ending
of sort of like it's like finding out
that the rules of the game were like the
word not was in front of all of them and
you didn't know that beforehand or
something like that yeah by the way I'd
love to hear you you don't have to
comment on this now but I'd love to hear
your thought on sank being the guy who
was really instrumental in getting the
squad I mean I've seen that video
nothing would surprise me okay okay
where did you leave the tail of Robert
Epstein
well I think he had been arrested I
think he had just been arrested yeah now
if you were too bright Oh God
if you were to write a a Brad thorn
novel okay how do you think this would
how what do you think might have
happened oh I'm gonna say something very
twisted go ahead but everything's
twisted everything's twisted he got
gang-raped in jail or something or now
he he he
hung himself in jail now I say it's dead
he's dead he's dead now here's the deal
he tried to commit suicide okay the
reason why I say hung I do believe he
hung himself but listen to this listen
to this so he tries to commit suicide
put them on suicide watch they move him
to this institution where the cameras
are on him 24/7 every 30 minutes someone
has to go and check on him they don't
even have sheets they have paper sheets
okay so you have it is for people who
are high profile high risk okay
it is the lockdown of all lock downs
like Hannibal Lecter yeah okay he hangs
himself with paper sheets could be done
can it be done yeah I think it could be
yeah I I do believe that he hung himself
but what makes it hard to believe what
is there video but you would think so
but the video cameras they haven't said
why but the video cameras that were on
his cell not anybody else but on his
cell malfunctioned both of them and
every 30 minutes they have to go and
check on him but those two guards both
fell asleep and why are you telling me
you believe this because I want to have
hope you know because it could have been
Trump or Clinton that had him killed I
mean there's a million people including
the Queen that wanted that guy dead yeah
now here's another reason that you might
not believe it his partner that was the
model agency chief okay right like the
guy that was like finding the girls yeah
and was the head of the modeling agency
okay he's just disappeared
they don't know where he is every bit of
him has been erased off the internet no
cell phones no nothing online that he's
ever done all erased and he's gone no
one can find him you know was when I was
leaving Candace's wedding and Jeffrey
Epstein not Robert I was like yeah I
sorry when I was leaving Candace's
wedding in Virginia Virginia is really
lovely I was by Monticello I'm sure
you've been there a million yeah
it's incredible Jefferson's estate I saw
a little cabin it's sort of very far off
the thing and I thought that would be
nice to live there I mean what that I
mean that's insane that's me I mean look
the guy was evil I mean he was truly if
anything they're saying about the guy
was true this was a truly evil to die
you know it looks it looks that doesn't
strike me as the story anymore no the
story is evil this is not the story you
know and now everything's just kind of
going away I mean this guy had more on
and I believe I believe he may have
killed himself because he knew once he's
released into general pop what could
happen to him what you said and what his
life was gonna be like I do believe that
that that is a big motivating factor if
somebody wanted to kill him disappearing
the other guy disappearing the two
cameras not working the guards were
asleep this is hearing it hearing that
all that right there it's like that's
exactly I'm talking about about why why
I pray that the media could actually s
reconstitute itself because you have to
yeah because wouldn't it be wouldn't it
be your greatest joy basically short of
like you know something with your kids
or your wife or whatever but your
greatest joy to be like do you know that
an honest decent media good people
started to rise up and now when
something insane happens where you're
you can go down that conspiracy road
forever right like that sounds far more
realistic some crazy conspiracy theory
then guys fell asleep at the camera
right mm-hmm but because we don't really
have enough trust in any of these things
any Bubba effect
yeah that's the Bubba effect there's a
and I didn't I didn't plan on talking
about this but you can't believe your
eyes anymore there was a video of a deep
fake and I can't remember who it was
anybody remember who this was gonna be
the next thing the deep fakes oh my gosh
was I here well the last time I was here
I think maybe I talked to you I know I
talked to Ben Shapiro last time I was
here about technology and what's coming
nobody knew what a deep fake was you
know 3,000 years ago I'm telling you it
we are now at the point now at the point
to where you can
to believe your eyes I can't nobody's
yeah well I've seen the videos where you
don't have nose with Obama and it yeah
like something you cannot tell now you
cannot tell last week there was the
first AI voice-recognition break-in so
some CEO had a voice code and it was
broken into by AI that wreak created his
voice they broke in stole all of the
stuff and that's again what I'm saying
about the speed we just you know cept
all of these new things in our life and
I'm not you know it's funny because I'm
not an anti technologist by any stretch
I love this like people in Silicon
Valley they don't let their own to have
it they don't use it have you seen that
that there's a still image of Zuckerberg
from like five years ago where they take
somebody took a picture of him standing
at his desk and he has his webcam
covered by and no audio think of right
tape and it's like wait and you don't
let your kids on this and Steve Jobs
didn't let his kids on right it doesn't
Bill Gates now that his kids are social
media what do you know that we don't
what do you guys been doing but we all
keep doing it again I include myself in
this I think that's why I want I really
I'm really going to try in the next year
to use whatever influence I have to
really try to to just I can't reverse it
and I don't think nothing can be
reversed everything moves forward you
don't but to want to stop the growth of
technology but we have to stop and think
think I'm doing this show tomorrow on
radio about this new technology I think
it's BCI
and it is now on with Zuckerberg
Zuckerberg and musk are working on it
they say now that through your neurons
they have an algorithm that can actually
take your neurons and place them into
words so now whatever you're thinking
lovely right and so musk is saying we
have to have a new bill of rights of
privacy that your brain is your brain
your thoughts are your thoughts and no
one has a right to take them they can
also alter them with this technology
how frightening is that pretty sure
there was a book written about
thoughtcrime
yeah and I think we're I think we're
veering we're veering into all of this
stuff and okay let me give you three bad
things that happen well that wasn't the
bad stuff no I wasn't that doubt this is
this is the stuff they're really kind of
matters right after you went on vacation
we had shooting in Dayton Ohio killed
ten injured 27 let me just tell you I'm
not going to use the name of the guy but
this is how he is described demented he
had a chilling Journal of demented
scribbling and satanic drawings spoke of
hunting someone at the University of
Dayton seek and destroy it said he was
very ADHD paranoid schizophrenic strong
bolt bipolar he ranted about drugs
violence and women referring to them as
[ __ ] even being dissatisfied by his
own looks they his friends said that he
was smoking methamphetamines all the
time when they were hanging out
he thought Donald Trump was a bad guy or
a dumb guy but didn't like Hillary
Clinton either what do you think the
what do you think the narrative was on
shooting number one well obviously he
doesn't control they said we never have
the conversation about mental health
which is correct or suppose that was gun
control in the atmosphere that Donald
Trump has done was it wasn't the Matt no
it wasn't the math and it wasn't the the
psychiatric problems that apparently you
know I'm guessing he wasn't a member of
the NRA no he he was not the member of
the NRA then we had another shooting
that happened thirteen hours later this
one happened in El Paso Texas
and Donald Trump was immediately
condemned because the media said his
manifesto talked about illegal
immigrants okay and how they were
invading the country so for two days we
had Fox News
stop using the word invade on the air
okay but I want to read his manifesto
because a we never read manifestos I
never do but this one is important to
correct the record you tell me who's
responsible my ideology has not changed
for several years my opinions on
automation immigration and the rest
predate Trump and his campaign for
president I'm putting this here because
some people will blame the president or
certain presidential candidates for the
attack but this is not the case the
event goes on talks about the need for
universal basic income for universal
health care and he ends like this the
American lifestyle affords our citizens
an incredible quality of life however
our lifestyle is destroying the
environment and our country the
decimation of the environment is
creating a massive burden for future
generations
corporations are heading to the
destruction of our environment by
shamelessly over harvesting our
resources this has been a problem for
decades brilliantly portrayed in the
decades-old classic The Lorax watersheds
around the country especially
agriculture areas being depleted fresh
water polluted from farming and oil
drilling he goes on and on and on he
ends it with this I just want to say
that I love the people of this country
but goddamn most of y'all are just too
stubborn to change your lifestyle so I
guess the next logical step is to
decrease the number of people in America
using resources if we can just get
enough rid of enough people that our way
of life can be sustainable does that
sound like a trump supporter to you well
that's half Thanos from Avenger yeah
like that's Libya and what Thanos wanted
to do it yes I just watch that was one
of the few things I did that involve the
screen but it's also that's what happens
with socialism right we've got a lot of
things wrong so we're gonna have to
clear out the brush and what's the brush
it's a lot of people I mean that sounds
like half Andrew yang with it with ubi
and then half the rest of the Democrats
up there so I can worry I mean I can
guess where it's all going with trumps
they blame Trump okay this weekend
unfortunately there was another shooting
this shooting happened in Midland Texas
and all of the candidates now are saying
that we have to have this has to stop
Beto came out with a slogan that like
excuse the language but like this is
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] and printed
t-shirts the saying that he's saying not
voluntary confiscation but actual
confiscation of guns Biden has said it's
insane that we still have magazines that
hold more than one round what are we
talking about going back to muskets
they're all talking about legislation
because these last two and now this one
first too sick if you want to blame it
on anybody you can blame it on
environmentalists that are saying all
this crap but don't blame it out they're
both sick yeah this guy sick this guy
was so sick that he went in to try to
buy a gun and the the background check
denied him yeah access to a gun that's
the last line in almost every story I
read that yeah that's in chat that's in
paragraph 13 yeah that's it as variant
doesn't fit absolutely only have the law
if and if you want to know who sold him
the gun it wasn't it wasn't somebody who
was registered to sell firearms so who
sold him the gun but that's the part
they never because they believe that
they can create laws that man can create
laws that can completely control man yes
and it is not it's not possible it's not
what the human spirit or either those
against everything that humans are it
goes against human nature at its core
it's why you have to kill people well
you may want to clean that quote up it's
why it's why fascist and communist and
those who are totalitarians
have to kill people because if thank you
for gonna forget where we are that's why
we have to kill be right Glenn Beck
ladies yeah no but you know what I'm you
know what I'm saying that's why they
think well we if we just get rid of
these people because they're standing
our way no but Helmand nature stands in
your way as it should but that's why
modern leftism and the progressives are
so dangerous because they're telling you
all they're hinting to us loudly all of
the things that they will do once they
have power because they believe state
power is the answer they believe they
have the answers their ancestors and
everyone that came before them was some
sort of backwards idiot or racist or
buffoon or wasn't evolved or any of
those things and what it I mean the
again the beauty of it is that it's a
snake that eats its tail but but so it
will implode but the question is how
much ground does it destroy when it you
have Ground Zero here but how much of
the rest of the goodness of freedom of
Western societies does it take out with
it that's the question that remains to
me see one of the things that didn't
come up in the news at all but I was
doing you know because everybody was
talking about the the tariffs and how
bad the economy is and the media is just
talking it down and so I did some
research
I think it's Denmark I think it might be
the people who just turned us down on
Greenland those bastards
but one of those Scandinavian countries
just took a trillion dollars of their
sovereign funds and put it into US bonds
and US stocks
okay US companies a trillion dollars of
their sovereign funds because Europe is
now at zero or below zero in Germany
you're gonna lose money on their 50-year
bond it's so bearish that they're saying
I can't even promise you that in 50
years I can give you more money we're
the only one producing okay the stock
market here is up 400% they're only at
67% of where they were in 2007 all of
these countries are flooding money into
our stock market in our bonds it's the
world saying whether they want to say it
or not please America hold it together
you are the last great hope I so so I
obviously I didn't know about that story
specifically but I so believe the
premise of what you're saying there
about
the Europeans feel about America which
is which is the reverse not all the
Europeans of course but it's the reverse
of what the media the media says now Oh
everyone's laughing at us several things
were the laughingstock of the world when
Jordan and I went to we went to all the
Scandinavian countries so we went to
Denmark we went to Sweden we went to
Oslo we went to Norway etc etc and
Sweden the show he was planning on doing
one show there it sold out in two
minutes so we did another show in
Stockholm and it was incredible because
whenever you ask Bernie or one of the
Socialists you ask them what country
would you like to be more like what do
they always say well the Nordic
countries we like to be more like Sweden
well we went to Sweden there was nice
people of all the shows that we did
those two were the ones that stuck out
to me the most because the crowd the
crowd felt desperate they were
incredible crowds the the applause the
passion all those things but they felt
desperate Jordan actually I won't try to
totally quote him on this but he gave a
really interesting story about how
what's happening there in the Nordic
countries is they've done it
the Galit arianism right men and women
are equal nobody debating any of this
but then as time has gone on for four
decades as this has been true where men
can do whatever they want women can do
another one but still because we have
biological differences sorry for my
racist that is sexist yeah just kidding
okay that men still become engineers at
a higher level and women still become
nurses so the social justice warriors of
the day crazy that crazy bomb insane
crazy that men and women are different
yeah but the social justice warriors of
the day who are now but many of them are
in Swedish parliament and they have the
first you know feminist government all
that they won't let truth they won't let
the way their own people who were equal
have made choices and men choose peers
and women choose to be still not gonna
be it's still I could have certain that
they want to go back in and re-engineer
their country so that tells me that when
I hear something like you just laid out
economically well of course it makes
sense because the people they are being
fed nonsense and then they're going us
us help yeah yes the Bill of Rights
here's here's what's crazy i went were
you in copenhagen yeah beautiful right
yeah it was great you ever seen a city
like that that looks like that it was
pretty good happen to be pouring the one
day i didn't get so it's just absolutely
gorgeous i was there for maybe two days
and it's just unbelievable I was
actually in a
Trond and I was talking to this longtime
resident cope from Copenhagen born and
raised and we were talking about I said
this is beautiful and she said well
we're not really unique you know blah
blah blah and I said what and she said
well that's kind of what they're
teaching now that we don't have anything
unique that other cultures are more
unique than ours aware cos kind of bland
and I said could you do me a favor would
you just walk outside with me for a
second she said why and I said just walk
outside with me for a second
I walked out sit on the on the sidewalk
and I said you see all those buildings
you see that architecture nowhere in the
world but here is that architecture
don't let anyone tell you you're not
unique that doesn't mean you're better
or worse doesn't mean we're better or
worse it just means you have something
unique here be proud of it you created a
sovereign nation it's has given
something good to the right he'll
basically respects human freedom right
you know I think we're leaders they were
leaders of the reason why they're having
problems now is because they've always
had open borders if you know if you are
tired and poor and huddled masses come
to Sweden they will take care of you
our promise was come in here and make
something of yourself
theirs was will take care of you but you
got to be a sweet-ass citizen now people
are coming in and there's country's
falling apart because they don't want to
be Swedish and the same people who say
oh we want to open waters please come in
also we'll tell you a horrible and
racist and evil we are thus propagating
the idea that we're gonna bring in
people tell them how impressed they are
tell them how much they hate the system
crazy
okay let me go to let me quickly go to
and I just want to mention again that I
do have these three big announcements
that well that will do at the end we're
finding out what time is where I have no
idea we're gonna do another like half
hours okay I'll do that
all right so let's talk about let's talk
about what you missed in politics
I completely forgot about politics wait
so who dropped wait so you're tell me so
okay so can I guess yeah
how many dropped green three three well
small well was out by the time I went
off so I'm getting all three dropped and
you already told me that Williamson is
still in now she didn't make the debate
but she's still in all right so she's
done then so that's it's fun and then
well
once you start getting out of the debate
they never let you back in and then it
just feeds on the fun grades but she's
out but she's got the power of love you
got the power
jealousy yeah so three dropped out well
I'm guessing it's it's got to be like
Inslee and sleaze out enslie's out okay
then there's the other guy that's sort
of Inslee like he would give me one of
the you know what I'll do something
crazy tonight that shouldn't go ahead
I'll pick one how about Tulsi that would
be depressing she did not make the
debate however she's polling above two
percent in like twenty of the early
states the Democrats just picked two
states where she wasn't pulling at least
two percent so she's not getting in but
she's not leaving I think I think she is
the one war like she is she you know she
left what were you here when she left to
go back to serve in the military
she left the campaign trail for two
weeks to go back to the military and do
you know her I don't I don't know what
her reserve status is but she had to go
back she did it with a smile on her face
left no big deal she just left and I saw
her and I thought the Democrats are so
foolish that woman could act she cuz she
doesn't hate the country everybody else
seems to hate the country
she doesn't now I don't agree with her
own policies but she seems like a normal
human being and I really think if you
just had a normal human being so many
people would Russian you know what I
knew they were gonna boot her no matter
what because this is about how corrupt
the DNC is when when she started getting
a little traction online you know I've
been pretty good I think it over the
last couple years tracking when somebody
starts somebody started getting a little
something and you doesn't sort of see it
not because I've seen this with Jordan
and so many these people she started
getting a little buzzed and next thing
you know BuzzFeed conservatives secretly
love Tulsi Gabbard you know like all
these stories that suddenly the frogs
and the trolls love her and it's like ah
they got the memo she's starting to
catch on with some interesting people
she wouldn't be a vote for a
conservative but she would be somebody
that you could go okay you believe she
loves the country
the Shiba she will put the country first
which was a big thing with Donald Trump
you know he nobody thought he hated
America they just loved himself more but
he didn't hate America that was a big
deal but you know there's a there's a
really ironic position for the Democrats
right now which is that someone like her
who was really running his anti-war that
was her main thing well Trump has not
been for war he called off the Iran
strike we seemed to be negotiating with
North Korea does anyone think we're
gonna nation-build under Donald Trump oh
you should have sue you should have
heard his speech I think it was on
Friday when he he talked about in this
nowhere today I couldn't find anywhere
on the end of the Afghan war he says we
are not nation-building again so but
then when a Democrat comes out really
anti-war well how does that even make
sense anymore now that's anything with
Trump so you then you again you get this
like crazy situation that no matter what
Trump says you think that's why is it
don't you think that's why people are
starting like to be uncomfortable
because they're like a crap I agree with
Glenn Beck or oh crap I agree with Dave
Rubin and we're very close we don't
agree on everything but we have certain
pretty big principles in common that
everyone else seemed to have abandoned
let I'll give you two people that you
know and like when Bridget fed Izzy when
I did her podcast was I was before you
did her podcast and she said to me that
she I mean you could listen to it where
she says she was shocked that she liked
you and the other one is my good friend
people go Xion well I love and adore
Phillip both of it yeah I love both of
them I do too he even was saying well I
can't believe it but here I am in this
this is a good man this is and I think
I'm pretty sure you might have did you
write the foreword for their book or you
you you I did something yeah you did
something it's like that's that's the
weird al' I look all the people that are
good it's great that's good it's great
that's I think where the country is they
don't want to aid people anymore and
we're not these cartoon characters
alright so Williamson out of the debate
and tulsi out of the paper they're both
still in it I guess
right the other two that might have
dropped did klore botcher hick Oh hittin
a little bird okay yeah I couldn't go up
with the name over and Gillibrand yeah
can I just
yes please Kristen Jill and Brad you
want to help reduce her campaign was so
I don't have my phone for you know for
30-something David I could find this
year
Kristen chillin brand where is this has
been texting me I don't know or her
people I got on their list and they've
been texting me and I repeatedly told
them in text stop messaging me they said
she's the only one that can stop Trump
blah blah blah no matter how many times
I tell them miss please Gillibrand stop
tech they won't
yeah I keep getting text fundraising
text so I guess what you're telling is
I'm not gonna get those fund you're not
gonna get those funder you don't have a
problem drawing I did here all right
doesn't matter so it looks like believe
it looks like Biden is still clearly
head however man he's he is hurting I
think he I don't think I something seems
cognitively not quite right I don't
think he really would have missed have
you seen him in the last 30 no is he is
he worse worse I think they asked him
last night he's the last chance for any
blue dog decide on the crash they they
asked him last night you know why do you
want to be President and he couldn't
really come up with an answer cuz he
doesn't want to be he doesn't want it if
he wanted to be president he would have
ran when Obama went out the first right
he didn't want the the powers that be
whatever that is I don't mean that in a
conspiratorial way I mean that the the
last remaining decent Democrats that
were the people in charge in the Star
Chamber yeah yeah that we're going holy
[ __ ] we're about to hand this thing to
AOC and Omar and the rest of these true
radicals who are going to destroy
everything that is good about America
they looked around and they said is
there one decent Democrat and they said
can we resurrect JFK is there anything
left
you know I know yeah but but Biden was
basically dragged and it's obvious he
doesn't want to do it it's obvious he
was the last year is why you're saying
when he said that that he told Obama
please
please his wife two weeks ago was
meeting was doing a fundraiser and she
said look I know there's a lot of
candidates that you might like much more
than my husband but he's the only guy
that can win so you got to get behind
him that's your pitch she liked me Wow
what I mean that's really it's sad and
it's pathetic and it's you know and
that's the other thing the last night
that it was I think July 31st just as I
was going off the grid was a democratic
debate I think it was the second night
of and I wasn't really paying attention
excited to tie up so many loose ends but
when I had it on in the background it
was like I just kept thinking why would
I want any of these people to be more
involved in my life I don't want Trump
to be more involved in my life by the
way either I don't blame any of these
people and they keep saying they can
solve all of your problems right have
they ever solved any of their problems
as Bernie Sanders ever created one job
of these people have they ever done
anything but if they only had four point
two trillion dollars to do this and it's
like there's no no I said two I guess I
am feeling sharp after hey I I was I
said once once Trump was elected I
called all my liberal friends and I said
see how you feel right now that's the
way the country has felt on the other
half for eight years yeah don't I can't
believe it don't kick them while they're
down don't do it it's a huge mistake
none of them none of them listened to it
but it's you we're repeating
exactly the same patterns just in
Reverse times a thousand well one of the
things that I really hope I can do in
the next year and I and I'm becoming one
of those people who says I write about
this in my book but I do write about
this book is one of the things that I
want to see happen now is on the right
so not really like the libertarian so
like you who I deliberately are always
decent and tolerant I find all the
things but one of the things that I
think sometimes libertarians have the
same disease as Republicans and
Democrats you're not libertarian enough
right so they have a strange purity test
yes you're like because then it's like
how far do you want to go to learn that
right that's what I would say but right
but one of the things that I think would
would really help a lot of what you're
concerned about here is is if the
Conservatives could say you know what
we're gonna carve out a little more
space for some secular conservatives for
some gay conservatives just we don't
have to agree with everything even even
say a pro-choice conservative which I
know would be a it makes no sense in a
certain way but we're going to carve out
a little bit of space not put it in the
party platform but just there's no it's
all Trump did with with Peter Thiel yeah
I mean he is I don't know how that guy
gets the most evil two gays ever award
but he does and you're like wait what
what has he done what has he ever said
here till at this RNC convention right
gay man standing yes I mean that was
fantastic fantastic the world didn't
cave in on itself and yet now everybody
in the gay rights industry and they use
the chlorine industry it's an industry
there always is the word crime
do you know Patrick Byrne is yeah do you
know him I don't I did meet him once
actually he said he was gonna do the
show I met him yeah so does he seem like
a kind of normal-ish libertarian kind of
guy yeah he's trying to do more with
Bitcoin and he would they would be right
so he has now come out and said he's had
to step down because of this he's no
longer the CEO of overstock
because their their their stuff was
crashing but he said in an interview
that he was in the center of both the
Clinton and the Russian probe and he
said I found myself in a Hitchcockian
sort of way he said I went to freedom
festive ever spoken to freedom a they
asked me so they he spoke at Freedom
Fest and and petrina what's her name the
the Russian metrand Maria
booty no yeah yeah you know she's in
jail for being a spy right okay so she
approached him and said so darling I'd
love to meet with you sometime well who
knew Patrick had a national security
clearance okay so he immediately calls
the FBI and says hey I
no she wants to meet with me and I think
you know Russians probably have
different standards than everyone else
and it could be great so I'd like to
know can I talk to her and date her FBI
said not a problem she's already been
vetted ok you sure yes not a problem
already been vetted so he starts up a
relationship with her okay then she says
oh you've got to meet my Russian friends
they love you and so he call he gets the
list of the names and he calls the FBI
um she wants me to meet these guys is
this ok what do you think of this I mean
it would be a little obvious but is she
a spy no we've already vetted her it's
okay third time she says Patrick darling
you've got to come with me I'm good to
meet with the Clinton campaign and I'm
trying to meet with Rubio's campaign and
so he calls again he says okay she is
going to be at this hotel meeting with
the Clinton campaign and the Rubio
campaign any interest in this no she's
fine she's not a spy okay so they
continue to date he dates her fur while
longer at all six eight months after
then Trump is elected
now the FBI calls him and he said that
it was I think he said it was Peters I
don't want to say I can't remember one
of the guys that you know yeah and said
Patrick we need you to rekindle a
relationship with her
and he's like what so we've already
broken up don't have a relationship with
her and you know what you guys told me
that she checked out and she did I've
met all of her friends she's not a spy
we need you to rekindle that he did he
reported back to the FBI definitely not
a spy she's got nothing going on the FBI
then took her tried her they did not
convict her of being a spy that was
tossed out for failing to register right
okay so she went to jail she gets out
like next month Patrick comes out and
says I know who the people were that
were directing me and they were all the
people that were investing
in Clinton and all the people that were
investigating Trump this is a dirty line
in the FBI Wow and our new Attorney
General I have confidence is going to
come out with the IG soon and expose
this but I was there I saw it with me
let's do this on his own volition cos he
said I kept quiet about it
I wanted you know American system to
work and people just to get it and and
now it's time for me to say something
and I think he put I think he was kind
of trying to put a little pressure maybe
on the FBI don't screw with this yeah he
stepped bet he nail you only did one
interview that he steps down the day he
steps down he does
wall-to-wall interviews which to me was
kind of like hey I just want everybody
to know I'm the guy who said the FBI is
dirty on this if I go missing or I hang
my shelf self with a paper
correct correct
Wow we don't know what it is yes suppose
I'll have to follow you will have to be
follow okay let me see there's a couple
of other things here that I think oh
here in Hollywood Debra Messing and the
other guy for the played will yeah will
she played grace they both came out and
they said they want someone to Docs all
of the Conservatives in Hollywood
because they need a list of that
everyone can follow of who not to ever
work with or employ is there no end to
progressive tolerance no how do they not
see that they've become McCarthy i'ts
yeah you know one of the last things
that I saw before I went off was do you
remember Bette Midler tweeted this image
of Trump at a rally and there were a
couple black people black supporters
with the magg hats on and she tweeted
something about their you know their
sellouts or something and she even had a
hashtag that would say you know sounded
racist it was like black it was whatever
it was it was like and I retweeted it
and you know her tweet gets a couple
thousand retweets and I retweeted it
said you know black people are
individuals and some may have different
political views than you'd like them to
have as a white liberal it you know I
invite her on the show but you know
I would love to talk to her but you know
I was being slightly itchy or whatever
but that that thing where these
celebrities think that I took acting
classes at one time long time ago there
nothing there nothing there just the
idea that Debra Messing knows anything
about anything or will knows anything I
can't even his name but he knows
anything about anything but I say that
because over the course of the month
that I was gone I kept thinking maybe I
should pay less attention to Bette
Midler but it's like when you see them
say something crazy you feel it
incumbent on you to fight back because
you don't want people to be brainwashed
by butch until they're the worst the
highest compliment is imitational
somebody is doing your act that's the
highest compliment you could give yeah
the biggest slam is I heard it from
somebody and they said Oh what you must
think of me
big enemy what you must think of I don't
think of you yeah walked away that's the
biggest slam I don't think of that
meddler who cares yeah who cares let me
give you just one more thing on YouTube
and then you can get to your
announcements this goes right into it
YouTube this month has banned James
Allsop don't know either I mean he's a
right-wing kind of or I shouldn't say
all right kind of guy I don't know
good or bad I don't know him okay
Facebook has banned epic times from
running ads I said what is that because
they're like they're it's like a it was
like a Christian I think a Christian
yeah thing okay
Seventh Circuit Court of Appeals has
heard the opening arguments of the prior
you a case against YouTube for
censorship
yeah and YouTube I know this happened to
a year ago given me a good sense when
you were when you were on the on
vacation you came back ben shapiro said
and they've banned alex jones yeah i'm
here to tell you youtube reinstated alex
jones hold on i want to shut the [ __ ] up
nope
they reinstated Alex Jones reinstated
Alex Jones now a day later they took him
back off but he was back for Adele why
give me a little more here no that's it
that's all I got some sensible thought
no they put it back on they put him back
on took him back off did they say why
they put him back on I didn't pay that
much attention to it why they took him
back off didn't pay that much attention
to it why they put him on I have no idea
why they took him off he's crazy maybe I
did I I mean and that's your reason for
taking him off last time yeah what are
you doing
that's a fine segue mr. Beck yes so I
will say one thing quickly about YouTube
that I think is the perfect way to get
me to all of this which is you may
remember that right before I went off
there was the leaker yeah who was
interviewed by James O'Keefe and one of
and this Google Insider said that one of
the people they're censoring
specifically said one of the people are
censoring is dave rubin so i made a big
brouhaha twitter because that's all you
can do i don't have an army of lawyers
to attack them I don't have I don't have
muscle behind me what can I do I can I
can use my voice as a citizen to
hopefully fight back I always find it
funny when people say are you
libertarians you're you're complaining
you're not allowed to complain because
you don't want the government involved
so you should just shut up and it's like
no no that's the beauty of you know if
libertarianism or classical liberalism
use your voice without demanding that
someone behave the way you want anyway I
finally I kept tagging Susan Wojcicki I
think there were Jesse I the YouTube CA
me I tagged her a million times finally
we after you know thousands of retweets
and people tweeting at her she finally
followed me I had a video chat with her
off the record for an hour with with one
of her people there and I'm not going to
betray anything that was said because it
was off the record then I said you know
I happened to be coming to Silicon
Valley and I'd love to come to YouTube
and I went to YouTube we had another
off-the-record conversation and again I
will not I will not betray that but I've
no said I will say where I started this
whole conversation hour and a half ago
all this thing is is a search engine
this is not a home for Thought too
flourish anymore well they have been
that at one time no she said last week
that people must be free to speak on
YouTube no matter their opinion but now
seeing that that's no no she means that
that's what yeah no she she they had the
biggest purge of people in their history
the same day she said that right because
because but that what that also isn't
saying to you which is the real issue is
how do we manipulate algorithms yeah we
do other things and again I won't betray
the author and conversation but I will
tell you that I got no answers to any of
the questions that I asked I'm just
telling you and it's you won't anyway so
that kid's gonna give me a segue to
three things that I want to tell you
right now there are three big
announcements that I've been teasing for
a long time one of them just happened in
the last couple links it's not it's sort
of related to YouTube but not directly
and then we'll get to the YouTube on in
the other one so first off you may
remember the story of young Kyle cashews
who has been on this show who was the
parkland student from everyone knows
from parkland Florida the the shooting
who what really got him thrust into the
madness of the mob was that they found
years ago when he was much younger that
he had said some things on a student
Google Doc and blah blah this is a kid
who graduated number one in his class he
was accepted to Harvard and then of
course the document leaks this is a kid
he was a kid at the time I think 15
years old writing some truly nonsensical
stuff you might have said some weird
things when you were 15 did you glen
back yeah yeah you google docs back yeah
yeah most people grow out of it yes
sometimes I'm you're young you might say
things right
some people don't grow out of it but
that's an assumption with them anyway
Harvard as probably everyone watching
this decided to rescind their offer even
though he graduated number one in his
class and just and they had the kid just
that kid he's a young man was he's just
so obviously going to be brilliant
brilliant and and fight for what he
believes in all yeah so Harvard rescind
his offer I I called Kyle I think it
started with an email and you know
you've been on the show so we know each
other and we chatted a couple of times
Kyle khushu is now the digital director
here at the Rubin report yeah he has a
real job we offered to pay his health
insurance but you know he's still young
enough that he
I don't know where did that come from I
guess his parents or whatever else I
guess but he has a real job he started
today Kyle is in the controller room
right over there Kyle Kyle he met you
earlier yep and he has a real job so
while his friends now going to Harvard
or wherever they may be going are gonna
rack up you know how many hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of debt
Kyle will have a real job and I'm
thrilled that we can afford him that
opportunity and I know this is just the
beginning for him so that that's just
that's number one number two you know
all obviously about the YouTube
censorship and the Twitter stuff and
paint what happened with patreon and
that you know Jordan and I in Sam Harris
and a bunch of other people at patreon
all that so the big debate which
philosophically which we've hit on here
a couple times for me has been do you
get the government involved or not so
without rehashing that whole
conversation and you know my preference
is that I would not want that right I
did what I thought was the right thing
which is I started tech company about
six months ago and we got I went to
literally one investor one investor I
got investment I started it with a with
a really great startup guy that I know
and we are building a seriously awesome
what will first be a Rubin Report app so
we're building it because what I thought
was I can't solve everyone's problems
first I want to solve my problem first I
want to make sure I can always
communicate with my audience I want to
make sure my audience can communicate
with me I want to make sure my videos
can be posted and if people actually
subscribe they can see them and not be
manipulated I want to figure out ways to
have real community building where
audience members can communicate with
each other without fear of censorship or
being currently I want to figure out how
to monetize that properly so that
subscribers because you know if you have
a subscription service you've eliminated
99% of the trolls because you can say a
lot of things about the trolls but the
trolls are cheap and the trolls are not
nobody's gonna pay me to troll me but if
you subscribe to me they will but well
if you didn't guess what I'm not
creating a platform order for everyone
where I'm gonna be hurting your free
speech I just won't take your money and
bye-bye you're gone so I think what we
have built here is a huge community
based subscription-based solution
to what I think is the giant platform
problem I think the platform we've
created an incredible Terms of Service
actually which once we were going into
beta I'll explain that in just a sec but
once we perfect this for me for the
Rubin report then we're going to invite
everybody to get their own app you will
have a Glenn Beck inhabit the blaze can
happen and you can be a gamer inhabit a
sports guy and have it out you can unbox
videos or whatever the hell else they're
doing on YouTube and you will be able to
create your own Terms of Service for
your own community this is geo and we're
not keeping any of your data period I
will never sell your data I don't want
your data I don't need this thing to
scale so that I'm worth the billion
dollars so every one of the issues that
everyone has been talking about all
along I thought I can't solve it for
everybody yet let's go small first yeah
so we've created a really great tech
company so the reason I'm mentioning
this is that so everyone that's a
subscriber of mine now at support Dave
Rubin comm eventually will have access
to the app and as of this week we're
gonna go into beta launch where we're
just selecting members that are gonna
help us test it through my team's been
testing it it's really it's cool when
you see this thing you're gonna be
impressed like this is not sounds
correct you know this is not some
two-bit thing like right did something
really cool here so anyone that
subscribes now or whenever support Dave
Rubin comm will will have a chance of
getting in the beta launch but then
ultimately I think I really think this
is it I think I think we did everything
we could do think about all the problems
seriously enough for long enough and I
met with enough people that we're gonna
solve things at a small level first and
then go from there let but let the
platforms do what they want to
manipulate the algorithms and I don't
need the government to stop coming in
and raiding the the YouTube offices I
even said to Susan in her office I said
you know I'm the last guy that's trying
to stop the government from getting yet
so you might might want to be a little
right open to my ideas but in any event
let them do their thing we'll see what
happens with Prager and Seventh Circuit
and I'm fine
with us all fighting this on different
fronts I'm completely fine with that we
have to so anyway so we go into beta
this week we're gonna select people that
are current subscribers and any new
subscribers know that subscribe right
now have you just have you the part that
I haven't been able to figure out and
crack is you know people say well
conservatives should have their own
YouTube no I don't want no I don't want
that but you need to be able to be in
the the e so I'm not leaving I'm not
leaving YouTube now they may not be
happy with me I've said a few things
here today and I'll still play by the
rules as they lay them out as lack of
transparency as they give us I'm not
leaving I'm gonna remain I'm remaining
on Twitter I'm gonna keep using all of
these platforms but what I felt was if I
can solve my problem first really build
a rich community where people don't have
to be destroyed by the trolls and hated
you know just it's endless fighting what
I want to treat my community in my app
the same way that I've treated these
conversations and I think we can get
thousands of people for we're already of
several thousand people but I think we
can get thousands of people from all
over the world but then also we'll be
able to communicate with each other and
guess what guess what when I do a show
in your local town instead of where I
would never put it I did it once on
Twitter where I said I'm going out to
this bar in New York City and actually
about 50 people came it was great but
noir that's not the most safe thing to
do but if they're on my app and you know
there's all sorts of business operation
I mean I our investor is it was fan who
was one of my patrons who lives halfway
across the world and he dug what I did
and said you know if you ever come up
with something one day and then one day
I came up with something I mean so this
is just the beginning of that and I and
I really believe that small is the new
big the platforms will implode on the
zone so I'm very excited about that so
we're going into beta so in support Dave
Rubin comm and we're gonna just select
people but then everyone that's a
subscriber will eventually get the app I
think we're gonna probably go to market
in about a month we've done some pretty
good testing ready and now finally one
other thing back and this is an
interesting one because normal people
when they enter a business relationship
you wouldn't announce it before you sign
the paper is that a fair thing to say
you'd say that you've been in the
business longer than I have yeah
but we shook hands right before the like
right but literally like crazy right one
second like they said three seconds you
said let's just shake yeah let's just
yeah so we shook hands on something so
I've been teasing two people for quite
some time that I wanted to figure out
other ways to distribute the Reuben
report because I know how many times
have to say it here but without beating
a dead horse I don't I just don't buy
the YouTube game anymore I just think we
have to be ubiquity
yes I want my stuff out there I don't
care how you watch it or how you listen
to it whether you like it in bytes or
the full thing of those things anyway
I've had offers from from pretty much
everybody we that anyone can think of
that have tried to make me offers and
the one thing that I've always said to
everybody is it took me this long to
become completely independent as we are
in my house I have no boss the chance
that Dave Rubin says something one day
and then Dave Rubin fires they've been
pretty slammed I suppose anything's
possible but every every offer that we
got basically I was gonna have to give
up some level of control there was gonna
be something related to what we produce
or or how we produce it or the amount
that we produce it or some version of
that and nothing worked for me then
about them whatever it happen even
remember anymore a certain amount of
time though I had started having some
conversations with Tyler who runs the
blades run the blades of it
they say the CEO glaze and obviously I
but I think with this deal you're my
boss right yeah I'm gonna be your I
think you're and you're gonna tell me
what so here we go so that was the thing
yeah so look the Rubin report is staying
exactly where it is if you have an on
YouTube the podcast is saying all my
subscribers are still getting everything
that they're getting but we will also be
distributed on the blaze we're gonna tie
some bonds between the incredible
infrastructure that you've built because
I've told you when I've gone to the
studios in Dallas you guys have awesome
sound stages and there's incredible
things that we can do yeah so anyway the
deal has not actually been signed our
lawyers were literally going back and
forth the last for the last you know
whatever but we did shake on it there
were some tiny little things we needed
to knock out the point is that you're
not my boss I'm not your boyfriend the
blaze subscribers along with my
subscribers at Dave Rubin comm will get
early access to the full episodes and
it's just the beginning of several
things that I think we're gonna start
doing together and I think there's
relative to the app we've already
started talking to your guys about that
as we can tighten the bonds and and more
than anything else I think those of us
that are in this we're all individuals
and we put primacy on that but there is
a way that we can
you're out something together that will
protect us and strengthen us and you
know everyone's so afraid of
associations these days and open up and
and I think this is this was the right
this was the right move so you're not
paying for production or anything like
that it's a distribution deal
no it's a distributing yeah the Reuben
report and it is sold to be doing it
it's what I wanted the blaze to be from
the beginning and I don't think talent
or anybody else was ready for it yet I
don't want to tell anyone what to do I'm
not anyone's boss are not running
anything at the place just let's just
gather and I'll gather your place you
can gather it my place we just have to
be ubiquitous because as you said they
are coming their government and why
would I rely on something that I know
nothing about
it's why I got out of cable television
yeah yeah I wanted to be able to call my
own shots not be how not have a gun to
my head just be who I want to be and
you're the same way why would we get
into a situation where one's controlling
the other that's that goes against
everything we wanted and I think it goes
against human nature in the way that it
can be accessed now and what a beautiful
thing that that the tools of technology
are now allowing us to enter
relationships voluntarily the way we
would want to on our own terms and all
that so again I have to look into the
thing I think I may be your boss I'm not
totally clear on that probably but I
think it's gonna be the beginning of
something great we shook on it already
so yeah that only knows what the lawyers
are gonna do to us now but but we'll be
distributed their 48-hour window on the
blaze I'm gonna do two specials with you
guys also you guys also are gonna we
have to figure out some of the details
on this but my subscribers are gonna get
some benefits with the blaze and the
blaze will get some benefits with my
subscribers and a whole bunch of other
stuff yeah and there's something there's
something that you know about that we
are going to be talking about probably
later at the towards the end of the year
or the beginning of the year that the
blaze is going to be announcing that I
think is really dynamic and your
critical critical piece to that so
I have one more thing for you okay my
people you know because I've got a
massive European could be a hundred
people in there yeah I had my people
make our dinner reservations tonight
yeah and we're going to Beverly Hills
we're going I'm er going to the belly of
the beast and I'm gonna walk away but
Beverly Hills is the place that's
Beverly Hills is the place that Deb
Debra Messing said you know I got to
kill all those people well we're going
and they have knives at the place we're
going today we're going I'm gonna walk
right in there we're going back and what
we're gonna see what happened that I
know here's my prediction my prediction
is that there are going to be people
that come up to us and they won't be
able to fully say it because there are
Beverly Hills but there will be a wink
we will be I get when I'm here it's the
only place this in New York City where I
just see people across the room and
they'll do this you know all right back
we're gonna shake in front everybody yes
sir and this is just the beginning my
friend and I'm gonna let you close can
you talk to the camera you're close
that's the show man this has been the
Dave Rubin report all rights are
restricted and no other rebroadcast and
less Major League Baseball condones it
thank you for having me on and thanks
for coming in and doing this and we'll
see you again I think that